when you've dated as much as we've dated
you just know I would have married him
the first night that we hung out
[Music]
Carly Pierce sat down with ET recently
for an afternoon of pampering in LA I'm
so excited to get out of the studio
right now because I am a new mom so I'm
writing the hot mess Express never get
my nails you however need to keep those
nails right because someone's got a new
rock um yes that's true and they
desperately need it Carly will tie the
knot with fellow country star Michael
ray in an intimate wedding later this
year
she said yes when he popped the question
in Tulum Mexico over the holidays he
decorated a rooftop balcony that was at
our hotel that overlooked the ocean with
rose petals and a dinner and a mariachi
band and just casual casual totally
we've known each other for five years
probably when you've dated as much as
we've dated you just know I would have
married him the first place
[Applause]
it is because the closer closer
the closed few videos out now was it
actually like fun and kind of sexy or
was a totally weird having all those
cameras around people have been asking
me oh you guys are like laughing I'm
like yeah because he was saying really
funny things about your he's very funny
we're both pretty goofy as it is so we
had fun but it was definitely weird
closer to you was written about Carly's
relationship with Michael and it's the
first single off her upcoming album she
hints that her fiance will be singing on
the project he's such a huge part of
this next phase of my life this new
album that I've been working on so much
this new single it kind of just feels
like the first chapter of like this book
that I'm writing at the moment it's
beyond that almost I've been working on
it really really hard I'm more proud of
this album than I think I've been of
anything that I've done so far I feel
like there's been a little bit more just
security of myself to create the album
that I really want to make I think it's
just an extension and an evolution of
what you've heard of me but I feel more
centered and more myself than I ever
have before what is that experience like
collaborating creatively with the person
that you love I've been a fan of his
forever we've played a countless shows
together before we ever were even
looking at each other in a romantic way
I think he would say the same thing so
to be able to come together and do
something together
I think the first song that we will
collaborate on is very much like the
start of our love story well so tell me
about wedding planning this is one of my
favorite topics in the whole world just
so you know I didn't know that I was
into it
just recently it's fine it is fine we
want to do it really small just with the
people that truly love us and
have grown up with us or know us as a
couple
I want it to be kind of boho whimsical
romantic kind of fairytale elements of
country but not too country like I don't
want calories to burn it I think it's
just gonna be really intimate and just a
fun party for the people that really
know us and love us
it's Carly Michael will you sing well
he's saying how important is the whole
musical vibe to the party so we
definitely want a deejay for the
reception cuz we want to do I don't want
to sing I don't want to hear him sing
either now think he wants to hear me
sing you get enough of that yeah we we
hear enough of that and see another back
but first the couple is heading to Vegas
for the 54th annual ACM Awards where
they are nominated for new female and
new male artist of the year respectively
and the ACMs are really special I
actually interviewed him two years ago
on the red carpet on my first ACM red
carpet as of course a red carpet
correspondent you are one we have
something so two years later to be
engaged it is I have like a shoe
addiction that's really bad and now let
me with a boy he knows he knows all my
my flaws of shopping and Vegas has
really good shopping yeah I'm not like a
gambler I'd rather just gamble in this
shopping
does he like to gamble I think he does
okay so I'm sure I'll have to go and
support it a little bit
or he can just give me the money that he
wins that's the winning answer I like
that while Carly has found her happily
ever after
she's also opening up about heartbreak
on her forthcoming album nicknames for
now CP to CP - yes honest we're gonna
hear a little of Michael there we're
gonna hear about how much you love him
we're also gonna hear some T about past
relationships so it's not just a
lovey-dovey record no and I really want
to make sure that people know that it is
not just about falling in love that's a
part of it but I heard someone I
learned more about myself I want to
empower women I have all kinds of shades
as any woman does to her personality and
a lots happened in two years it isn't
all good
[Music]
Oh
any wine themed follow me you're
definitely gonna hear lots of wine
references because I've been drinking
while writing songs I love it ok let's
check out the nail all right girlfriend
looking awesome well thank you so much
for being here you're so glad we got to
have girl time you guys so much for
watching we'll see you again very soon
[Music]